des images du parc lafontaine qui sont
tristes parc lafontaine qui a besoin
d'amour
avec nous anie samson luc ferrandez on
va se faire un panel municipal sur les
sujets sur un sujet que moi j'aime
beaucoup comment on traite nos parcs à
montréal est aussi on reviendra sur
l'histoire des tanks de sans abri ça
recommence ils refont leur apparition
mais c'est un article du journal de
montréal cette semaine louis et philippe
messeiller le journaliste qui
interviewait notre camarade josée
legault qui habite tout près qui se
désolaient de l'état de son parc et
aussi de la rue saint denis mais restons
pour les fans la discussion sur le parc
dis moi comment ton parc et je te dirai
dans quel genre de ville tu vis
alors le tx france avec vous le problème
avec le parc
entre autres dont on parle la fontaine
c'est que on dirait qu'on on a laissé ça
pour des projets qui n'arrive jamais
plus à chaque année on dit ça va être
réglé c'est jamais réglé par plusieurs
choses à dire d'abord madame legault
ont pas été tout à fait honnête parce
que dans le parc lafontaine une énorme
énorme 2-2 énorme chantier en place il
ya la zone famille ou y avoir les plus
gros jeux d'enfants de du québec et il y
a le théâtre de verdure qui est en
reconstruction c'est la raison pour
laquelle des étangs sont vides c'est pas
parce qu'il ya un problème de
maintenance ceci étant dit il ya aussi
un problème de maintenance dans le reste
du parc élan elle a raison donc il ya un
désamour du parc parce que d'abord c'est
un parent qui est habitée de nuit 1
c'est un parc ou une faune de nuit très
vivante vente de drogue ou parfois juste
des gens kitchen même est très très très
tard dans la nuit j'ai aujourd'hui
encore je reçois des courriels des gens
qui habitent autour du parc c'est
ambitieux faire que j'étais maire à
l'époque continue de m'écrire pendant un
à trois heures du matin ça continue de
hurler mais la musique rentrer dans vos
appartements le parc la fontaine c'est
un cas particulier et aussi un autre
affaire c'est pas simplement la nuit
c'est que il ya une depuis environ je
dirais 6 7 1 une résurgence de la
fréquentation des parcs ses 40% minimum
de plus des
utilisations différentes causes justes
pour le sport des gens qui vont pour
pique [ __ ] pourboires et la capacité
du sport dit par les dépasser bon annie
est ce que vous achetez la rumeur de
l'udc qui s'est sentie un peu attaquées
non je blague mais à peine parler non
les propos de josé qui comme citoyenne
10 a pas de bon sa wii terre de la
verdure ya un chantier mais tant que
toujours en chantier mais bref annie
qu'en pensez vous mais je vous dirais
que la ville s'est toujours en chantier
ont le vue je pense qu'il m'a eu manque
de la mort un peu partout mais
effectivement parc la fontaine puis je
dirais la plupart des grands parcs
urbains à montréal depuis la pandémie
les gens ont appris à sortir c'est à peu
près la seule chose qui pouvait faire
don qui sortait et on voit que nos pas
ils ont envahi les parcs le la ville
c'est peut-être pour ajuster à cette
grande demande donc mettre plus de
poubelles les ramasser peut-être plus
souvent se met une équipe de joe qui
rament ans le jour une le soir une la
nuit il ya des moyens de rendre de
s'adapter à cette nouvelle clientèle qui
utilise l'impact parce qu'on veut on
veut que les gens aillent dans nos parts
mais de l'autre côté on dirait qu'ils
vont qu'on n'est pas capable s'assurer
que le parc soit en bon état aussi qu'il
ya aussi la responsabilité des citoyens
on voit plein de déchets flingue
détritus bas il falloir aussi que les
citoyens soient sensibilisés que c'est
aussi leur parc c'est comme dans leur
salon ils peuvent projeter des choses à
terre il faut mettre plus de poubelles
probablement que ça pourrait régler une
partie
il va falloir qu'elle avait innove c'est
pas une question que j'ai pas ce qu'il
vient de faire un surplus de 100
millions bon donc c'est pas une question
d'argent mais dans plusieurs parcs y
avait soit des cafés autrefois uni des
lieux des toilettes il y en a plus on a
eu cette discussion là sur le parc
angrignon lui que l'an dernier j'étais
allé faire un reportage sur l'état
lamentable de cerner en coin du parc
angrignon qui est magnifique par
ailleurs mais est-ce que
sérieusement laisse qu'un jour quelqu'un
va proposer un programme pour vraiment
prendre ça avec les deux mains pi2
d'avoir un programme réaliste pour que
nos parcs manque d'un cran oui
absolument c'est ce qu'il faut faire il
ignore on a parlé de problèmes de
poubelles le problème c'est que les
poubelles sont jetés pendant toute la
soirée une partie de la nuit ils ont
ramassé le matin quand la première
personne qui se présente au parc le
battait c'est odieux il ya des poubelles
partout alors oui des équipes de
ramassage de poubelles c'est pas comme
s'il en avait pas actuellement il passe
on vous a repourvu des dix poubelles
mais la capacité l'achalandage est
tellement grand il faut le prendre en
considération nos parcs sont devenus un
peu comme dans les places publiques en
ira avant il n'y avait pas ce type
d'utilisation est là et si magnifique
moi je surprends des conversations de
touristes par exemple équivaut parc
laurier au parc lafontaine au parc jarry
une foule immense au parc jarry oumhani
pour en parler le parc de la visitation
aussi un achalandage extraordinaire et
qui se surprennent de cette qualité de
vie c'est-à-dire des parcs de ce qu'ils
sont non clôturés qui sait où il règne
une certaine paix ya pas de poignée s'il
n'y a pas de bataille il ya des gens qui
m'ont les fermes pas la nuit comme à
paris vous devez cesser voilà c'est ça
on est plus floue et voilà c'est une
magnifique force mais là maintenant il
faut mettre des ressources qui vont avec
cet achalandage là il faut il faut
arrêter faire des promesses mais pour le
faire il faut le faire mettre des cafés
mettre des toilettes année conclusions
sur les pandas effectivement faut
rajouter des toilettes c'est le gros
problème de nos grands parcs parce qu'on
dit aux gens allaient passer la journée
là mais souvent les toilettes publiques
quand il y en a dans certains parcs sont
barrées et ça c'est une grosse
problématique faut trouver une façon de
pouvoir permettre aux gens d'y aller
dans avec des toilettes sécuritaire et
de l'autre côté effectivement il faut se
donner les moyens de nos ambitions on
doit tous mans de rester en ville il ya
des perturbateurs phone c'est
intéressant bain donnons leur la chance
pile allant dans d'autres villes à
l'extérieur de montréal et puis tout est
là le tout est beau tout est propre
pourquoi on n'est pas capable de faire
encore une fois c'est parce qu'on les
aime qu'on veut qu'il soit encore mieux
voilà très bien alors à ses gardiens de
parcs de ce fait des années chaque
campagne électorale municipale depuis
une vingtaine je dis pourquoi vous
ajoutez pas votre programme le retour
des gardiens ou d indienne de pareils à
temps plein qui a une présence humaine
tout le temps puis j'ai jamais de
réponse claire patrice patrice si je
peux me permettre au parc lafontaine le
gardien une pâte pour fermer le parc la
nuit ça va paraître disait fort
justement
qualité très douteuse oui retour des
tentes est-ce qu'on va ré assister au
revoir des images de 40 miles la rue
notre dame il ya survie géante saint
laurent et saint-urbain et notre dame à
l'auteur d'alphonse des rois et la voie
ferrée est ce que c'est un c'est le
retour de chasse que c'est inévitable
l'udc qu'est ce qu'on fait alors il ne
faut pas tolérer de camping urbain à
aucune condition une seule tente c'est
là c'est le signal de la possibilité de
s'installer là pour d'autres et à la fin
d'été il va y en avoir 50 60 70 et en
plus on a une expérience qui nous
démontre que et c'est là l'expérience de
la place émilie gamelin pendant une
année on avait toléré
les gens qui dormaient là pendant la
nuit ça attirer des gens de partout de
toronto d'ottawa de québec de l'a22 de
toutes les villes du québec et c'est
inévitable
et quand il y à un campement il y a
aussi une chose inévitable à la longue
il y à des agressions de l'insécurité
des problèmes de santé on l'a vu l'an
passé on le vieux deux ans ça se termine
toujours comme ça alors il faut faire un
pacte social non au camping absolument
non au camping dans les villes dans nos
villes en échange de plus de services
pour les itinérants en échange comme
vous êtes de plus de services mais
fermeté des services position les sports
s'installer des gens a ni excuse est
d'accord mais plus ou moins d'accord si
les gens sont là maintenant camping
comme ils le font c'est qu'ils ont un
problème qui est permanent donc c'est
encore depuis trois ans on en parle du
camping du campo et à chaque année ça
revient pourtant chaque année on nous
dit ok on les enlève mais il va y avoir
des solutions on va avoir des logements
va s'occuper d'eux l'autre qu'on se rend
compte c'est que les programmes ne se
suivent pas les années se suivent mais
les programmes ne suivent pas la route
et il ya de plus en plus ces points de
nouvelles c'est pas une surprise le cas
des itinérants à chaque année en a de
plus en plus quelles sont les solutions
viables on le veut la ville aujourd'hui
s'est fait critiquer dans le rapport de
la vérificatrice générale et dans le
rapport de l'ombudsman en disant vous
mettez des programmes en place vous
faites pas de suivi vous n'avez pas de
données probantes vous n'avez aucun
résultat sur les programmes que vous
avez mis en place pour savoir s'ils sont
bons où ils sont pas bons et l'on
s'étonne aujourd'hui dubaï a encore des
tentes ils vont continuer en avoir de
plus en pus temps qu'il repas de l'avion
je voulais laisser vous êtes le pouvoir
en ville voulait laisser sur place vous
vous demandez aux forces policières les
enlever moi je laisserais pas sur place
mais je leur offrira un endroit où aller
parce que là on les met où ils peuvent
pas disparaître parce qu'on veut pas les
avoir ils vont traîner dans les rues ils
vont au coucher devant les commerces
dans les entrées des appartements il
faut que ce soit quelque part et on veut
nous il n'y a pas encore assez place
mais ça fait trois ans que
l'administration travaillent à leur
trouver des places ayant disputé juste
un instant un lieu clos mais cet hiver
là il envoyait au stade de sa queue dans
saint michel puis au psi 20 a terminé
merci bonjour vous allez vous promener
dans les rues on n'a pas réglé leur
problème on leur a juste dit vous avez
été chanceux de dormir au chaud mais
maintenant il fait un peu froid mais
restent dehors parce qu'on ne peut plus
d'endroit pour vous c'est ça qui est
dommage la ville a les moyens de se
trouver des endroits pour gérer les
jambes c'est pas des comme l'on veut
leur donner peut-être à regarder ce qui
s'est passé à gauche la gauche on en a
parlé de l'hôtel qui accueillait des
chercheurs versailles en avait 150 lits
sont dit on arrête sur le contrat est
terminé on les envoie dans le sous-sol
de l'église 75 places dans le sous sol
d'église on fait quoi avec les 75
langues globablement qui sont dans le
camp tu ne bouges ajouté bon c'est bien
clair c'est bien clair qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes sans domicile fixe
qui préfère être dans un camping à orbey
pas d'où un même si le pack toilettes
préfère être là que dans le refuge par
exemple dans un endroit où il faut être
sobre lorsqu'on rentre il faut parler un
peu des espaces il ya des horaires fixes
c'est clair mais la ville c'est un
paquet de petites contraintes
contraintes de bruit contraintes de
circulation contre de pollution tout le
monde doit faire un effort pour que la
ville soit vivable viable agréable et
inde un de ses unes de ces contraintes
la cie l'itinérant l'itinérance
acceptons d'usiné rose faisons plus pour
l'étudiant on n'est pas obligé d'aller
jusqu'au point où ils ont des parcs ou
la pub les espaces et là vous mettez la
ligne vous dites oui mais non très bien
merci à vous deux merci beaucoup à
bientôt peut on ira se promener au parc
lafontaine après les travaux du théâtre
il avait dû revoir si la fontaine va
couler puis searle au milieu puis si si
si merci beaucoup à vous deux nos
adresses mesdames et messieurs cas
pensez vous de nos parcs
[Musique]